ces trois produits peuvent être gardés
stocker 100 x préparer ensemble comme
nous allons le faire
ils vous donneront un excellent petit
déjeuner ou un goûter reconstituant
convenant parfaitement aux personnes qui
ne supportent pas le lait par exemple 60
grammes d'amandes moulu dans un moulin
électrique avec 60 g de sucre six
secondes suffisent pour moudre les deux
surtout pas plus avez vous remarqué les
amendes ne sont pas épluché vous
ajouterez à cette préparation 30 g de
cacao non sucré et si vous n'avez que
les amendes et le sucre
vous mettez un filtre dans une casserole
et le cacao les 30 grammes de cacao dans
le filtre
[Musique]
vous ajoutez le sucre les amandes pilées
plus ou moins vite du reste
vous versez sur le tout 700 grammes
d'eau froide et vous mixez
[Musique]
vous retirer le filtre et porter à
ébullition
[Musique]
mais faites très attention seul hic qui
debout exactement comme le lait et se
sauve de la même façon
[Musique]
ce cacao d'amande est une boisson idéale
pour les sports d'hiver
[Musique]
il